Prof: As you may have
noticed, the course has been
proceeding somewhat
historically.
First with pre-primate animals,
the whole evolution of sex from
things that swam in the ocean,
and then we discussed the
primate mating system as you've
seen--
in the same sense as on the
board.
The first--the pre-primate is a
few millions of years--I'm
sorry, tens of millions of
years;
primates maybe ten million
years or so.
Then last time we started
discussing the transition from
ape to human,
and evolutionarily modern
humans date to something like
150 thousand years ago.
We're coming up to time and
today we're going to discuss
fully anatomically modern
humans.
They have the same brain
capacity that we do,
etcetera, etcetera.
The earliest groups that we
have any kind of decent
demographic data on are hunter
gatherers which would include
cavemen and people that are
hunter gatherers but do not live
in caves.
Last time we asked why there
were so few chimps and so many
humans and today we're going to
ask very similar questions
about--
we're going to start with,
we're going to cover a lot
more;
we're going to ask very similar
questions about hunter
gatherers.
There never was a great density
of hunter gatherers.
There is certainly not now and
the question is,
why?
If you look where hunter
gatherers live now they--
each small group,
and the again the small group
is the same size we've been
talking about something like 40,
are spread out over a very
large area and they use that
area to hunt in and to collect
fruits and nuts,
and whatever they can get from
the trees.
It looks like a very simple
question, why is the density of
hunter gatherers so low?
Why are there so few of them?
For a long time,
the answer was:
they didn't have much food.
That they needed all this space
to get enough food to survive,
and if they overpopulated that
space they couldn't survive.
In sort of modern hubris,
we looked back and thought
hunter gatherer is a very
inefficient form of food
gathering,
not modern, and we're so much
better than them now.
The data is quite clear on some
part of those assumptions;
hunter gatherers,
at the time when all human
beings were in the stage of
hunter gatherers,
before--farming starts about
10,000 years ago.
There's--what is the number
here?
There may have been like two
million people on the whole
earth.
Remember I said hunter
gatherers spread out of Africa,
spread amazingly over the whole
earth,
and maybe the total population
of humans at that time was
something like two million
people.
Now we have over six billion
people, that's an increase of
3,000 times in the human
population, so clearly there
were fewer hunter gatherers than
now.
This is a very--you'll see this
in lots of discussions of this
field, but it's a very
elementary kind of
consideration.
It talks about the long scale
of human demography,
of human population growth,
and we came out of being other
species of primate,
of hominids and we gradually
grew up to some sort of a limit.
There's the idea that the
various productive systems that
we use,
like hunter gathering--limit is
some sort of a carrying capacity
limit,
and so the idea is that the
human population increased until
it reached a limit and then for
a very long period of time it
can't get beyond that limit.
Then 10,000 years ago,
maybe it's 12,000,
farming is invented and all of
a sudden the whole system
changes,
there's many more people and we
jump up and then again reach a
limit,
and we'll talk about that as
some Malthusian limit in this
particular period,
later we'll discuss that,
and then around here the
industrial revolution happens
and all of a sudden the
population increases again.
This is a logarithmic scale so
it's not linear.
Each of these jumps is by a
factor of several thousand.
That's a very,
very schematized version of
human demographic history and
we're talking about this period.
What limited hunter gatherers
to this level whereas farmers
could go up to this level.
Again, the obvious answer and
looking at this kind of rough
data is that it was food.
Whoever then--archeologists,
paleontologists go and actually
try to examine this and there
turns out to be the data does
not fit that theory terribly
well.
What do archeologists do?
They dig up skeletons and they
have a good representative set
of skeletons from the last 7,000
years in North and South
America.
One study looked at more than
12,500 skeletons so we're
talking about a good scientific
sample.
What did they find out?
These were set into
communities, and communities
lasted so much time,
so you can date the whole
archeological site to a certain
period.
The medical anthropologists got
into it and started looking at
the bones and dentition and all
this,
and not only did they find the
violence we talked about last
time,
but these people were also sick.
They had diseases at different
times.
You could see bone problems and
how well the bones grew and from
the teeth how much calcium they
had, and all this.
What does it turn out,
that contrary to the idea of
progress that you'd think the
later people were more healthy,
in fact, it was earlier people
in the--
the earlier individuals that
were healthier.
As time goes on,
the skeletons get less and less
healthy, that they're getting
less food and less good food,
and were more subject to
diseases.
It was quite a shocker when
this status started coming out.
The researchers attributed this
decline in health in large part
to the rise in agriculture.
Two main factors they say,
the rise of agriculture and the
rise of urban living,
and we'll talk about the urban
story in a moment.
If you again go like we did
last time from the archeology to
the anthropology and look at
current hunter gatherers,
it's a little bit of a
distorted study because nowadays
almost all hunter gatherers have
been pushed out of the good
lands that they used to live in,
into very marginal lands.
You know this from
U.S. History in high school,
how the European farmers pushed
the very earlier farmers or
hunter gatherers of the American
Indians,
the Native Americans into
Arizona, into desert,
into the Badlands in the West,
the dry Badlands and to the
West of the U.S.,
farming peoples push hunter
gatherers into inhospitable
land.
There's a story in the
Smithsonian Magazine recently
about Pygmies in Africa.
I don't know if you know a
little bit about the history of
African demography,
which we'll also cover,
but the Bantus have expanded
from south--
the bulge of southwest Africa
basically all around and have
pushed other people's out and
the Pygmies are one of the
groups that have been very
severely discriminated against
and really pushed into
inhospitable places.
Another example is the Bushmen
of Africa who were pushed into
the Kalahari Desert in southern
Africa.
Even in the desert these guys
eat 85 different species of
plants,
and it's almost inconceivable
in their culture,
for someone to die of
starvation because plants will
bloom some years and not bloom
some years.
They will get a fungus some
year, or a virus,
plants--any one species is not
generally very reliable.
When you have 85 different
species to survive on you're not
going to go without food.
There will always be some group
of plants that are going to be
available to you and so you're
not going to starve.
Further, the anthropologists
lived with these people and they
start writing down what they're
doing at every point in time.
Per hour invested,
the Bushmen get more food then
the early agriculturalists.
Not modern agriculturalists who
can drive a tractor and in an
hour do a lot,
but we're comparing
hunter-gatherers to the first
stages of agriculture.
The Kalahari--the Bushmen in
Kalahari spent 12 to 19 hours a
week collecting food and the
rest of the time they used for a
lot more sleep than current
farmers,
and a lot more leisure than
farming people,
so life is more generous to
them.
You have to think now,
this is for people pushed into
a desert,
a very inhospitable place,
and now if they--
if you can imagine them living
in a lush forest region where
they originated,
life must have been much,
much easier so the amount of
time exerted to get your basics
of food and everything must have
been much-- a lot less.
Not only do they have to work
less and they get more food per
hour,
but the variety of foods is
very good for you because you
need different minerals,
you need different other
micronutrients,
you need different vitamins,
and as we are bombarded with in
the popular press,
a variety of foods is very good
for you.
You don't want to eat just one
kind of food,
so they had a very diverse and
healthy kind of diet.
Agriculture comes in and indeed
it enormously increases the
amount of food per acre when
land is limited,
when you have a population
density such that land becomes
limiting rather than your time
or your need,
when land becomes limiting then
agriculture becomes important
because per acre you can get a
lot more food than hunter
gathering,
but you have to spend lots and
lots of hours to get that land
to give you that amount of food.
The question remains 'why are
there are--why were there and
still are of course,
why are there are so few hunter
gatherers?
Again, a Malthusian type
question that,
if we know they lived quite
well, we know that later people
going into agriculture lived a
lot less well in terms of basics
of life,
how come the hunter gatherer
population did not increase up
to the same level of misery as
early farmers,
which is basically one of the
earliest examples of a
Malthusian type question.
Malthus thought those same kind
of thoughts but for a much later
population.
Well in truth,
we don't really know the answer
to this and it's greatly argued
about, but I can tell you some
things that are known.
Current hunter gatherers have a
moderate number of children and
many survive.
They do not have an enormous
infant mortality,
certainly not compared to later
populations which I'll show you
that have a huge infant
mortality.
If they are Nomadic,
and I'll tell you about an
example of that later,
they have to move quite a lot
and that means carrying children
around.
I think Bonnie has sort of
indicated to you,
even dealing with a lot of
children in one place is
difficult,
but the difficulty of moving
with very young children,
and packing up everything and
moving for a very long time,
over a long distance is
difficult and Nomadic peoples
very often show very clear signs
of some form of conscious
population control.
They know they can't cope with
more than "x"
number of children.
We'll get to that all societies
have indeed controlled their
population but mechanism they
were not totally--
not clear what they think the
reason for their doing things
were,
but Nomads apparently know what
they're doing.
Hunter gatherers are moderately
healthy.
Again, their burden of sickness
is not severe,
again compared to later
populations;
however parasites are always a
problem.
I'll show you again a modern
case of parasites.
This is a girl,
modern girl,
current girl in Central
America, and you may notice the
swollen belly.
You know what's inside there to
swell it?
Worms--exactly and when they
purge her that was what was
inside that girl,
all those worms.
Humans have had this problem
since time in memorial.
Hunter gatherers are not immune
to this.
Infectious diseases they have
less because they're in small
groups,
so infectious diseases as you
know need large groups to keep
spreading and they're hostile to
their neighbors,
just again like chimpanzees so
they don't come in a lot of
contact with neighbors,
so diseases don't spread from
group to group and each
individual group is not large
enough to allow for the
maintenance of a disease.
Each village,
if you--anthropologists go and
sit in one village for a long
time and they have a high
population growth rate.
Each village seems to be
expanding quite noticeably,
and you think,
well in each village that we go
study population is increasing,
again, it doesn't make sense
why haven't they--
been living that way a hundred
thousand years,
why haven't they filled up
their space?
Why is each village surrounded
by lots of--basically unused
space?
Even today, a lot of the very
tropical lands are not
high--densely populated.
We may have the image that they
are but they're not.
New Guinea is not densely
populated.
If you call densely
populated--the Netherlands is I
think the most densely populated
in the world,
Bangladesh, the livable regions
of China,
the livable regions of Japan,
these are densely populated.
The tropical regions of the
world, nothing like that;
New Guinea I said,
Borneo very sparsely populated,
the Amazon, Sub-Saharan Africa
vast open areas,
so these are not situations of
high population density,
yet any village that you sit in
is increasing its population.
What's going on?
What are the--what the
archeologists find out is that
when they study a site,
and I sort of mentioned this
already, what you see is this.
You go to--you start digging a
site and you actually dig in
reserve,
but you go to the bottom and
you see there was nobody there
before certain years,
and then a small population,
and what you see,
you can count the amount of
food remains,
all kinds of things,
the population grows more or
less exponentially.
That means that the same
percentage every year.
A half of a percent a year or
whatever it is,
and it grows up faster and
faster, because there are more
people producing that same
percent of population growth.
You get this phase and then all
of a sudden you reach the top of
your pile and your village is
gone and there's nothing there.
Some sort of a crash happened,
where if it's not totally gone
it's really knocked down
tremendously,
and then you either wait--look
at that site again like the
biblical sites which they dig,
and dig, and dig and sometime
later starts up again,
or a different site starts up
again and you get the same
phenomenon.
Forget this line,
this is the idea of -- the
carrying capacity,
but you can see nothing fits
the carrying capacity.
It just maybe stays there for a
little here, so the idea of
carrying capacity for humans
doesn't work very well.
What are the reasons--so--then
the explanation for the
population staying more or less
constant and not filling up the
space is not that each community
doesn't exist,
but communities--here's your
space filled with community A,
B, C, D, E and as each
community increases some other
community just disappears,
goes out of existence.
If you measure over the whole
big space you have a floating
game of different communities
each growing,
but then disappearing
completely, and the population
and the whole space stays more
or less the same.
I don't want to push that as it
really becomes super duper
constant, but more or less the
same--does not fill up.
What are the reasons why a
community would grow very
happily, more or less,
very vaguely,
exponentially,
and then go out of existence?
One is of course climatic
disaster.
There could be a freeze;
there could be a drought,
these real climatic things,
and if you look at the Anasazi
of Arizona that lived near the
Colorado River regions,
one of the thoughts--they're
one of the communities that fit
this.
They're healthy,
you go see their ruins,
and then they just disappeared.
How many of you have been to
Anazasi site in Arizona?
Just one student,
something you've got to do.
There you're living in a
semi--a true desert now and a
semi-desert back then,
so climatic things are a
reasonable explanation.
You go into the tropical
regions you don't have droughts
that last, you don't have
freezes, and yet you see this
same kind of phenomenon.
While undoubtedly climatic
things happened occasionally in
the temperate zones,
certainly in the northern
zones, most hunter gatherer
societies probably that's not
the explanation.
The next thing is diseases of
the crops, that some fungus came
by and wiped out your crops.
Well we've just talked about
that, that since they're eating
85 different kinds of things in
the desert,
there isn't any kind of
microorganism that cuts across
species like that,
so that explanation doesn't
seem to work.
Diseases of humans,
same thing, not diseases of
plants,
but diseases of humans,
again, the data just doesn't
fit that,
that because of the isolation
they don't have a huge problem
with communicable diseases.
That leaves the possibility of
violent confrontation from one
community to another.
We've seen in the chimps how
the northern group will
completely wipe out the southern
group and so forth.
What kind of evidence can one
adduce that this might be what's
going on?
If one looks at any modern
population and looks at the
survival curve,
so this is the number of deaths
per 1,000 per year.
This is India,
for instance,
and it's fairly recent--1960s.
Antibiotics are just coming in
at this stage,
so very high infant mortality
rate,
80 per 1,000--one out of every
12 kids dies almost immediately
and then that high rate
continues until about--
comes down to something about
six or seven years old so a lot
of your population is just wiped
out immediately.
Then you have a pretty low
level of death and fairly flat
until it gets to be what's
considered old age in different
populations and then the death
rate rises.
You have this very standard
u-shaped curve,
and here after you have sort of
modern medicine--
this is Sweden in the same year
as the infant--
primarily the main thing is the
infant mortality drops like
crazy and the old age stuff--
everything drops but the main
drop is in infant mortality.
The idea is--what I just want
you to get out of this--
we'll see this graph again and
again in a couple of times,
is that during the adult years
the death rate is very low
compared to either here or here.
Now if you look at what we can
gather from archeological data
from hunter gatherer
communities, you have a high
death rate of kids.
Not as high as when you get all
these communicable diseases in
modern societies,
and then you have a flat
period, and then all of a sudden
there's this big bump.
What they call an excess
mortality in exactly the young
adult years,
and then it comes back down
again and you get a more or less
normal old age situation.
Well what is it that kills
people in their middle years?
Violence.
So this kind of data--again we
don't totally--
we don't really know the
answer, but this kind of data
leads you to suspect that indeed
one of the major reasons,
not the only reason,
but a major reason that the
hunter gatherer communities and
the early archeological
communities disappear so
suddenly is that they are wiped
out by some sort of violence.
We're right back in hunter
gatherer times as far as we can
tell to what you've seen before
of these mass--
I've showed you last time these
mass graves that are
characteristic of this period.
Okay, nevertheless,
over the very long scale of
time--
our period of being cavemen and
hunter gatherers lasted hundreds
of thousands of years--
but gradually population did
slowly increase,
and as population increases,
the land available to people
gets less.
We talk, I think next time
about Africa,
which has a culture where land
is not a scarce commodity and
now it's getting to be scarce,
but in their traditions,
land is not the scarce
commodity,
but as the population grows the
land per person gets less and
then you have to make a more
intense utilization of the land
and farming gets invented.
A big discussion whether it
actually was the population
pressure that caused farming to
be invented or whether that was
just some brilliant stroke by
somebody that invented--
that people slowly figured it
out.
They actually can trace the
origin of agriculture to--
the current data is 11,700
years ago in the Middle East,
in Anatolia,
what's now Turkey,
now eastern Turkey,
and it expands on the average
from the original sites you can
watch it expand and it expands
at one kilometer a year.
That's the average.
Then it eventually takes over
the whole world.
The number of people,
and when you invent
agriculture, the number of
people that can be supported on
one plot of land grows up
enormously.
We've seen that and so these
people become more numerous and
so in military confrontations
and warlike confrontations,
they're going to be dominant,
almost no matter what the
technology is,
no matter what the bravery is,
if you have an awful lot more
people you're going to wipe out
or push out groups that don't
have that kind of population
density.
Agriculture spreads;
in the early days of
agriculture you don't know an
awful lot yet and you probably
have one crop that you really
know how to grow.
For instance,
in the Americas,
the big crop was corn that most
of Latin America even to this
day lives on corn,
and the North American Indians
lived a lot on corn.
Of course in Southeast Asia a
great big population,
it was rice,
and you basically lived off
most of your calories,
most of your food from one
single crop.
That's not very healthy because
each crop is missing something.
Corn, you may know,
misses lysine,
one of these essential amino
acids and over a very long time
the Americans learned to--
a rather complicated procedure
for boiling it in lime to
extract this amino acid from the
plant,
but until that was discovered
they must have been extremely
unhealthy.
Rice, you know,
is missing all kinds of
vitamins and people have very
severe vitamin deficiencies if
their diet is too much rice.
You're not getting a health--in
early farming you're not getting
a particularly healthy diet and
you're not getting the vitamins
and micronutrients that you
need.
Furthermore,
your food security goes down.
Again, as I've mentioned,
that a virus or a fungus,
or something attacks your
crops, and that's 80% of your
calories and that is wiped out
in a year you're gone.
Or if locusts come by and eat
them up or some insect
infestation comes through.
Also an increase in calorie
availability;
you can--more people can stay
alive and so you get dense
populations.
The social structure changes,
now previously each person
could only get enough food
basically for himself and maybe
a very small family.
As you develop the technology
of agriculture,
an individual can produce a
surplus, not everything he
feeds.
Well who's going to get that
surplus?
In an egalitarian society he
keeps the surplus himself,
his family, and so forth.
But there's other guys that are
either stronger and nastier then
you and they come in and steal
your surplus from you,
and they have to leave you just
with a small part of your
production to just keep you
alive because they want you to
work for them,
and so you get societies now
where there are classes.
There are people who in way or
another take the excess food
from the farmer and use it for
other purposes,
usually their own purposes.
They can largely hire military
to keep them in power and to
protect them from other places.
That's a large use of the food
surplus which agriculture puts
up.
Also manufacturers come in;
they hire artisans to make
beautiful gold objects for them,
or to make beds,
or chairs or all the
manufacturing starts on the
agricultural surplus that
agriculture brings in because an
individual human now can produce
more calories than he needs to
keep going at a subsistence
level.
What you see as agriculture
progresses is the hunter
gatherer societies are generally
quite an egalitarian.
They'll more or less have a
head man but he won't--or a wise
man or an old man,
but they won't have authority.
He can't order other people
around;
the community has to agree on
some project if they undertake
projects at all.
As more food wealth becomes
available,
societies start stratifying,
you get social classes,
you get castes,
and this inequality changes
everything about the way humans
live.
The congestion in the
cities--cities start growing up
and then you start getting the
spread of these infectious
diseases where one person
spreads it to the next in large
agglomerations of humans.
That just gets worse and worse
up through the 1400s in Europe
when you get the Black Death and
wipes out a huge number.
That is--as civilization
progresses the death rate from
infectious diseases just keeps
going on up.
Adding all this together and
the data we have,
is that hunter gatherers--their
lifespan is ballpark 50 years.
In early agriculture societies
that goes down to 35 years,
so we're really--and I'll show
you data that in a lot of places
it's probably even lower than
that.
We have this situation where
humans--
not counting violence that
humans live--
when they weren't being
attacked by their neighbors,
humans were living very well,
the hunter gatherer society;
sort of Garden of Eden.
Then agriculture comes in and
the vast mass of humans become
peasants;
the land becomes owned not by
them but by someone else,
and they have to give most of
what they've produced to someone
else,
so life becomes miserable.
There's a lot of thought that
the various of Garden of Eden
myths--
I mean almost every culture has
some sort of glorification of a
very distant past where people
did not have to work so hard.
In our culture we call it the
Garden of Eden;
everything was perfect,
then something happened,
and after the fall of one sort
or another, now it's the sweat
of our brow.
It's a very nice description of
what I've been telling you of
the hunter gatherers living in a
lush environment--
before they're pushed into the
desert--
living quite well,
and however,
later on then they have to be
farmers,
the sweat of the brow.
And violence like Cain and Abel
is what is the fly in the
ointment of that beautiful Eden
story.
Now we come to the agricultural
period in our historical romp
through history.
There are some really
fundamental issues that you have
to understand to understand what
was happening with population in
these times.
There's constraints on human
population, and the first was
this enormous infant mortality
which I showed you.
Again, we're looking at 1960
here in a very civilized place,
poor India in 1960,
but still even into the 1960s
where we're very modern,
the infant mortality is
enormous.
You go, even currently,
to a less well developed place,
just cut out this quote from
Haiti in 1979,
before this recent rash of
problems,
a Cornell trained Haitian,
comes from Haiti to Cornell,
gets a medical degree,
returns to Haiti,
and he gets a job at a
pediatric hospital:
"40% of the infants,
of the babies,"
the birth rate--
he's working in among other
things a maternity clinic,
"40% of the babies were
dying of endemic diarrhea.
A man would come to pick up the
bodies three times a day with a
big bag.
The noise of the skulls in the
bag was unbearable."
And this is 1979 in--how far is
Haiti from Miami?
A hundred and fifty miles or
something like that.
The data--we have various data
sets for what life expectancy
was like,
and this is various populations
and what this is,
this is a survivorship curve.
So you take--for 1,000 people
born in any given space of time,
in an earlier period--so this
is Cisalpine Gaul,
this is Roman times,
that's the part of Gaul that's
this side of the Alps according
to them,
Cisalpine Gaul.
Out of 1,000 children born,
and actually this shows females
but it's more or less the same
for males, almost immediately
half of them die.
That's very characteristic of
human societies until modern
sanitation comes in,
which is in Europe 1700s,
and in Asia maybe 1900s.
You have this tremendous death
rate of children and then it
continues at a fairly high but
decreasing death rate,
and then finally there's very
few people left.
This is not the curve which
showed you the percentage of
death in age thing,
but how many people are still
surviving?
At any point in--by age 15
here, this dotted line,
only about 40% of people are
still alive, 60% have died
before age 15.
This again is women,
so a lot of these deaths in
this middle period,
by the time--this is the
reproductive years,
these dotted lines is 15 to 45
or so,
I think 50 in this case,
which is the years in which
women can reproduce and most of
the death in females in this
period is childbirth itself.
In a developing population,
in a pre-medical population,
childbirth itself is one of the
most dangerous things in these
years and the death rates are
very high from childbirth
itself,
so a lot of that is female--is
childbirth.
If you looked a male population
it might even be more extreme
due to the--probably due to the
violence that we've talked
about.
Now as times goes on--we're
going to come back to this
graph,
but as time goes on,
this is Italy in 1921 and
things have gotten--
at all ages the death is less,
so there's more people
surviving,
and then you come to Japan;
again 1984 and you have very,
very little infant mortality,
very little mortality through
this period and then again old
age takes over and people do
die.
This kind of bump here compared
to say this, is again possibly
violence in that era,
but again, we don't really
know.
For our purposes,
going back in time,
we're really interested in this
lower graph which is
characteristic of humans from
way back until really almost
Napoleonic times,
maybe through Napoleonic times
but the death--
the violence in Napoleonic
times was enormous.
If you look at women,
consider this just a graph for
women.
Of 1,000 women born,
400 are still alive at the
beginning of their reproductive
period and about 200 are still
alive at the end of their
reproductive period.
If you average that out
something like--it would be the
same as if something 300 women
lived throughout their
reproductive period.
Well, if that society is going
to keep going,
what is needed to happen that
these more or less 300 women
have to reproduce 1,000 women,
right?
If they reproduce 1,000 women
they also have to reproduce
1,000 boys.
So 300 women have to give rise
to 2,000 children and if they
don't do that then there's fewer
and fewer people in each
generation and rapidly you don't
see this population anymore.
How many children is that that
each woman has to have?
Three hundred women making
2,000 children--
6 2/3, almost 7,
so that means that in--
when you have a mortality curve
like this,
which again is most of human
recorded history,
most of human history not
counting hunter gatherers who
did live longer apparently,
the absolute minimum that a
society could cope with is women
have basically an average of
seven children.
Wait a minute,
I've made this a better case,
that's of the--all that this
graph shows is women that are
alive in this period.
What fraction go infertile?
What fraction have infertile
husbands?
What fraction never get married?
What fraction are too sick to
have children?
What fraction of women are worn
out after two or three children
and can't bear many?
That's also a very large number
which depends on the population,
so if you subtract those--let's
call them infertile women for a
variety of reasons in which they
or their husbands,
or their health they're
infertile, then there's even
fewer people alive and so this
curve goes--
if you didn't graph just women
alive but women that are alive
and in childbearing condition,
the curve gets much lower,
so the number of children that
women--
the women that were physically
capable of it had to have in
these pre-modern times was more
than seven,
and probably eight or nine,
or you have to do the
calculation and people don't
know how to evaluate the--
what fraction of Roman women
were fertile or infertile?
You can't calculate that.
We have a huge problem that
somehow there must be cul--
there must be mechanisms to
insure that no women are wasted,
that any woman that can
reproduce does reproduce,
and when they reproduce they go
at it.
They just keep going and going,
and of course men have an equal
part--well they don't do the
amount of work but they have a
part in it.
As I said, this level of
mortality continues into quite
modern times,
it's quite striking.
Europe got out of it a little
bit earlier, I say somewhere in
1700s, but for instance in 1912
in Australia--we have an
Australian T.A.
is she here today?
Went to the--she got a ticket
to the inauguration--1912
Australian census shows that 60%
of all children born died
unmarried.
That's this number,
we have them--well it was about
the same number as this,
this shows that only 40% are
left and this says in Australia
60% are dead,
so that's the same number.
Sixty percent of children born
died unmarried,
and among the married one-ninth
of marriages were sterile,
and just 11% of the men and 14%
of the women produced half of
the children.
That means those that could
reproduce and were married and
had to really have very,
very high birthrates,
as late as 1912.
China, as late as 1930,
had a nearly aboriginal birth
and death rate.
The total fertility level was
at these levels of six,
seven, eight children per
woman, yet the population was
not increasing,
which means the death rate was
just as high and they were in
this kind of a situation for
reproduction.
We're going to talk a lot about
China later of course.
At that death rate,
and this is data for China,
in order to have a 50%
certainty--so as you know many
cultures,
and Chinese included in
traditional times,
for sure wanted at least one
child to survive.
They do a calculation at this
death rate how many children is
the minimum you have to have to
give yourself a 50% chance of
having one son survive;
five children.
If you're not thinking of
reproducing the population,
but just reproducing your own
family which is the way
individual families think,
and they have to have a son and
you have this mortality rate,
at five children you have a 50%
chance.
If you want to have an 80%
chance of something you're back
up to eight,
nine, ten children which
explains the desire--
not necessarily--they don't
necessarily keep this birth rate
but the desire for these very,
very high birth rates.
The result is that in most
pre-modern societies,
women spend their whole
post-pubertal lives either
pregnant or lactating.
There's basically never a time
when they're free of the
biological aspects of
childbearing,
not counting the children that
are now not breastfeeding
anymore that Bonnie was talking
about.
For instance,
in Bangladesh in the 1990s,
we're coming up very--75% of
the women in the age group of 20
to 39 were either pregnant or
lactating.
That means four out of every
five women were,
at that moment,
any moment that you look,
they're either pregnant or
breastfeeding,
and there's a small period in
which they rest and then it
starts over again.
We're not talking--in the need
for these very high birth rates,
we're not just talking about
primitive tribes by any means,
we're talking about the period
in which all the world's great
civilizations developed.
Civilization--one of the things
that civilizations had to do was
insure a birth rate like this.
In the period in which cultures
were learning to write and
producing a classic literature,
and developing the great world
religions,
all of these if you read
through them are calculated in
some sense to keep fertility
high.
All of these things glorify
high fertility.
The religious doctrines push it;
there's community sanctions;
the cultures just developed in
a way that--
in order to increase fertility
and any culture that doesn't do
that and doesn't increase it
successfully,
they're just not here anymore.
Of course most cultures that
you read about are not here
anymore, and they were not
successful.
In our Western culture,
the most famous of these things
is the First Commandment in the
Bible: be fruitful and multiply.
Well that fits us,
if you didn't do that then the
Hebrews would be gone,
and we wouldn't have any of
what we currently have in terms
of religion;
any kind of the monotheistic
religions.
There's all kinds--you look at
the culture--the religious
tradition of any culture,
you'll find all kinds of laws
about regulating sexuality.
Now, Yale students don't know
much about the Bible--
how many of you know--you know
masturbation is supposed to a
bad thing,
do you know what the Bible is
supposed to prohibit that?
Student:  Story of Onan
spilling his seed.
Prof: Yes,
so it's the story Onan spilling
his seed, and do you know why he
was spilling his seed or what
the situation is?
Student:  There's
different versions,
one is that he was having sex
with his brother's wife and
didn't want to impregnate her.
Prof: Why was he
having--so she said he was
having sex with his brother's
wife and didn't want to
impregnate her;
that's correct.
Student:  Well he was
doing it because his brother had
passed away,
and according to the Levirate
marriage tradition,
he was then supposed to do it,
in order to have a kid that
would--
have his brother's kid,
but he didn't want to have a
kid that would count as the
brother's kid,
he wanted his kid to count as
his kid,
so he would always pull out and
spill his seed on the ground,
and God said that's immoral and
struck him dead.
Prof: Right,
exactly correct.
I have to repeat this for the
camera.
The situation--it's a very
short passage,
a very interesting passage,
and it's giving out various
moral--
it's in a section giving out
moral laws,
and it says,
'someone had sons and one of
them was Ur,
and Ur was married,
and Ur died.'
It doesn't say much about Ur
except that he died.
Onan was the next brother.
Repeated in the Old Testament
many times is that if a man's
brother dies he has the moral
obligation to inseminate the
sister--
the sister-in-law--in order to
secure an heir for the dead
brother.
That if he fathers a child with
his sister-in-law then that is
not considered his child,
it is considered the dead
brother's child,
and that's one of these
important things of carrying on
the family lines which is one of
the ways of course insures a
high population birthrate.
This is a way of keeping women,
whether they're married or not,
whether their husband is dead
or not,
you've got to keep them
reproducing or the culture
disappears.
Why doesn't Ur want to do--why
doesn't Onan want to do this?
Well he may or may--it's not
his kid so it was born--
there's none of this sort of
power and authority,
and macho stature to come with
having a lot of kids because
it's the brother's kid,
in the culture it was the
brother's kid,
but on top of that he would
have to support this kid.
Economically he would have to
support not only the wife but
the kid,
and he didn't want to have to
support kids that weren't his,
so he engaged in the sex act
because that was the fun part of
it and--
but at the last minute he pulls
out and spills his seed upon the
ground.
Then the Bible passage is very
curt, it doesn't say more--and
then God killed him.
There's not a lot of
explanation for this.
It's repeated,
this particular law called the
levirate laws,
as a student said is repeated
in several places in the Bible
and it's very,
very clear that people didn't
do this.
People did not insem--did not
want to inseminate their
brother's wives because of these
reasons and so whenever you see
a law sort of demanding
something over and over again
you know people weren't doing it
and that's why the law is
demanding it.
That's just one example of how
religion gets involved in
enforcing fertility,
and in this particular example,
it's one of the mechanisms for
keeping every woman pregnant as
much of the time as possible,
independent of her state of
marriage.
The--anybody know why the
Muslims took to polygamy?
Why Mohammed allowed four wives;
no Muslims in the class?
Student:  To free women
from slavery.
Prof: What?
Student:  To free women
from slavery.
Married women--that's the
version that I remember.
Prof: No.
The standard version is they
were going through a lot of
wars.
The Muslims were conquering the
whole world, they were
constantly at war,
the men were getting killed.
There weren't enough men,
so what do you do with the
other women?
They--I mean many reasons but
one of--
they need support and so it's a
beneficial thing,
but their society needed more
men, more children,
so let them get married
multiply.
You just--whatever religion you
want to look at you'll find
similar kinds of examples.
When we get to family planning
issues later on,
how people controlled their
reproduction,
one of the major beliefs that
the early--
we don't really know again,
but in the West was that the
mechanism people used was
coitus interruptus,
because it was the only thing
they knew about.
It's in the Bible,
it tells you what you do,
it tells you the result of it,
and so that Onan passage is
currently interpreted to say
that masturbation and
contraception,
all kinds of things are bad,
when in fact the passage has
nothing to do with that.
That's not what that passage is
about but that's what it's used
for today, but it's been used
absolutely for the opposite.
People use this,
oh that's how I can avoid
having children and so
it's--culture twists itself
about and has unexpected
consequences.
Okay, so I've been stressing
for you that culture pushes up
fertility and up to this high
limit.
What is the limit of human
fertility?
We have to evaluate that.
There's a very famous
calculation of this and it's set
by the number of years a woman
is fertile,
which is generally 15 to 45
more or less,
it can be a little bit younger,
occasionally a little bit
older,
but they usually consider 30 or
so years of fertility.
At that--well if she gets
pregnant, she's pregnant for
nine months.
Ovulation rarely starts again
before at least three months,
if she's lactating and
therefore going through--
not ovulating again,
there's going to be more
months.
If a woman has sexual
intercourse it takes an average
of five cycles to get pregnant.
When we talk about abortion
we'll talk about why that is,
but if a woman's having normal
sex trying to get pregnant,
the average is five months
before she actually does get
pregnant and we'll see where
that comes from.
If the child dies,
fetal mortality introduces a
month there--
anyway you add all of this up
and you get 18 months that--
pretty much the maximum that
human females can do is 18
months or one and a half years.
Dividing--what they usually do
is choose 20--
any particular woman will
probably be fertile for 25
years,
divide that by 18 months,
and you get a theoretical
possibility of 16.7 children.
Now how many of you know
somebody's who has had more than
that?
What's the maximum number of
children you know about?
Student:  I know someone
with 18 children.
Prof: Eighteen;
I'm bid 18.
Only one in the class?
Student:  I think the
world record for a woman is
somewhere--it's really high,
much higher than 18.
I thought it was like in the
60s.
Prof: Oh, no not 60.
That's really crazy unless
there's some crazy multiple
birth.
Now with modern drugs sometimes
there's multiple,
but not 60.
This is an unusual class,
but as time goes on,
families get smaller and people
don't remember.
The maximum I got out of this
class was 24 children.
I think it was a Chinese
student, I don't totally
remember,
and that 24 was only two sets
of twins,
so there were 22 separate
successful pregnancies,
two of which produce twins,
24 children,
one woman.
Even--forget this--independent
of this calculation which I've
just sort of sketched for you at
the--
even before the calculation was
done and the person who did the
calculation knew about it--
this is not--here is
the--Norway in an earlier set of
women which is this set,
and a later set of women,
and this is the number of
children that the women have,
and the percentage--the per
1,000 of women that have that
number.
In the late 1880s the most
common number from Norway--
again we're talking Norway
1890, we're not talking about
anything very primitive,
is 10 children.
The mode for Norway was 10
children and it goes out to 18,
which was the record that
someone here knew.
There were--of course if you
had a bigger assembly you get an
occasional of something more.
Student:  The world's
record it's 69 children.
Prof: What does it say?
Good for him--what--that's
something special;
does it say anything about it?
Student:  She has--
Student:  Sixteen sets
of twins, seven sets of
triplets, and four sets of
quadruplets.
Prof: Okay so it
was--what was the total number
of--yeah so--okay I was wrong.
Send me--both of you send me
the reference for that because
next year I'll use it.
Now, just as long as I've got
this slide up there,
look what changes.
We go from 40 years later,
not a huge fraction of time;
we're going to talk about this
later in the class.
It goes from the mode being 10
children to the mode being 2
children.
Something drastic happens in
between these two in 40 years,
and this is common over Europe.
This is just one data set and
we're going to talk about that a
since it's up here.
In this period of time that
we're talking about women had
this very un--
in the mode there's a very
large number of children and
they far exceeded what's
calculated as the maximum.
Let's see okay,
the answer is that the
biological limit is very high.
I'll say 24,
you say 69, and we have to read
that stuff.
In a human population,
and continuing for any length
of time, the highest
well-documented fertility is
that of the Hutterites in the
1920s.
Anybody hear of Hutterites?
It's a Christian religious sect
that are an--
what's called an anabaptist
sect that originated in Europe,
migrates here,
they're in the upper mid-West
in North Dakota and going on
over into Canada,
and they're very successful in
both economic ways and in
population ways.
They marry fairly early,
not extremely early but fairly
early.
They have a good diet,
they're farmers and very
productive farmers,
and they have good medical
care.
They engage in sex regularly;
they're supposed too,
and their religion forbids
contraception or abortion.
Not only do they have--they
obey these rules.
Many people have those rules in
the books but this is a very
religious group and they obey
the rules.
Their, what we call total
fertility rate,
which at this moment you can
consider the average number of
children that a woman in that
society would have was 12.4
children.
Nothing--that's high--you think
that's high, I saw someone
blanch here, as an average,
but nothing like the 24 or 60
that we're talking about.
This is the highest human
population that we have
documented, can have that,
and it's nowhere near any kind
of calculation for a limit.
The most usual limit,
and you see a lot of cultures
in at least some part of the
history where the--
eight is current cultures were
or historical cultures where
eight is kind of a maintained
average.
In the colonial United States,
for instance,
for a short time when the
frontier was wide open they had
a fertility rate of eight
children per women,
but as soon as the frontier
would close in a region the
fertility rate would drop.
It's clearly land availability
had something to do with it.
There's good data for
Massachusetts,
Concord Massachusetts,
very good demographic data
there.
People had these high birth
rates until the frontier closed.
What did the frontier mean in
1600s in Massachusetts?
It meant like Springfield,
these were people living in
Plymouth,
and Concord,
and Lexington,
right near the coast and the
frontier was Springfield,
and as soon as--if they had a
lot of children,
the children would have to move
out to Springfield or somewhere
which is 100 miles or something
like that and that was beyond
the frontier.
As soon as the children had to
move more than a day's horse
ride away the fertility rate
drops,
so there's something about
having the support of your
children,
really having a group that
increases the fertility.
As soon as the children will
have to disperse and not anymore
be of some sort of support to
you,
or some part of your group,
fertility comes back down.
No society really has ever come
close to the biological limit.
Before we talked about how
culture pushes up the birth
rate,
but now we see that something
is pushing down the birth rate,
that we're coming to an
intermediate level.
What's going on is again fairly
straightforward and simple.
That it was this slide that I
want--here is again fairly
recent data.
Chinese women interviewed in
1981, but referring to their
pregnancies which had been
sometime in the past and it says
it tried to gather data on what
was the birth interval of your
children and how many of them
survived?
If the birth interval was less
than two years 45% of the
children died.
If it was between two and three
years, 34% of the children died.
If it was more than three
years, only 19% of the children
died.
In every culture and every time
and place where we have data
like this it's very clear that
if the birth interval is too
small,
the children just don't survive.
What's going on with pushing
down the fertility rate is that
it--
especially in situations of
poverty where resources are not
great,
women are not especially
healthy, there's no--
any kind of medicine available,
that if the child does not get
a lot of resources,
which a large case is milk from
the mother is the primary
thing--
in China there's no dairy
products at this time in this
social class.
It's largely food directly from
the mother;
the children are just going to
die.
The reason that fertility is
pushed up from below,
is pushed down is not to reduce
total number of children but to
maximize surviving fertility.
What people aim is not to just
keep popping them out and having
them die.
What people aim at and cultures
have learned to accommodate to
is to maximize surviving
fertility.
Not total fertility,
which is just being born,
but maximizing the number of
children that are going to stay
alive to become adult
reproducing members of the
society.
Now people have many mechanisms
for limiting the birth rate.
One that is often quite
conscious is breastfeeding;
it's a very standard method
across many cultures.
You've all heard of this,
lactation amenorrhea,
and many, many cultures don't
leave--
I mean in our culture a woman
can breastfeed a little bit or
long,
it's totally up to the
individual.
Many cultures are very strict
rules about this.
You must breastfeed for at
least--and there's a certain
period of time.
Among the !Kung of Southwest
Africa, which these people speak
this click language,
they've got all these--you've
heard of them.
Mothers keep the infant with
them at all times,
they nurse all day,
at intervals separated by only
15 minutes.
Bonnie how would you like to
have that all day long?
Nurse every 15 minutes the
child;
they sleep next to the mother,
and have access to her breast
all night long and the nursing
continues until the child is
more than three years old.
By that mechanism,
primarily by the lactation
amenorrhea, the birth interval
among !Kung is four years which
fits--is beyond this survival
issue.
This is the kind of--I talked
about Nomads and people that
have--
fairly conscious--they're
probably are aware that this is
limiting the births and it's
something that they want to do.
When the women go foraging they
carry their children--
again the !Kung,
they carry their children with
them until their four years old
and while carrying the infant
she walks up to 12 miles round
trip to--
it takes 6 miles to go out and
find some food and come back;
12 miles round trip and then in
addition to that she carries
loads of 15 to 35 pounds.
Here's a woman who--being a
hunter gatherer is probably
fairly healthy,
she's carrying an infant on her
back,
walking around 12 miles,
and coming back with a load of
35 pounds of food.
It's quite a feat and it's
clear that they can't--
they're not going to have a
second infant,
one on the back,
one of the hip,
this is not a way of improving
survival.
That's--lactation is one
mechanism.
There's many taboos on sexual
relations, especially after
birth.
In many cultures,
as I said, a prescribed period
of nursing.
There's also a post-partum
taboo against having sexual
relations, and again,
another obvious mechanism for
birth spacing.
If you--again this gets to the
degree of consciousness of these
methods.
If you ask a member of a
society that has a taboo they
report for instance that sex at
that time is very dangerous,
a life and death matter.
It is dangerous to mix the
man's blood with the woman's,
and the man's blood is
transmitted through semen.
It's a bodily fluid and they
don't totally--the biology is
not very strong.
Their course at Yale was
terrible--we'll talk a lot
about--
not a lot--some,
about what pre--pre-education
people believe about
reproduction and everything.
If man's blood gets into the
woman through his semen then it
also gets into her milk,
and then the man's blood goes
back into the baby through the
mother's milk and this is poison
for the baby.
That's their version of why
they shouldn't--why they have
this taboo.
We see this in the evolution of
cultures,
I mean just as we evolve
biologically,
of course evolve culturally,
that cultures may--
will pick up a behavioral
pattern for who knows what
reason,
and they may have no clue what
it's 'real' as we see it,
it's 'real' purpose is,
in this case to space births
apart they have some kind of
cultural story about it and it
doesn't matter whether that
cultural story has any degree of
reality.
If they've picked up a cultural
norm that works,
the society is still here,
and that gets passed on.
If that cultural practice does
not work, not only reproduction,
all sorts of ways,
that society is gone.
This post-partum abstinence is
a major issue,
especially in Africa now.
The abstinence is up to three
years which is--that's sort of
the mode of this in Africa.
In addition to limit births,
there's another thing which
again is a population limitation
issue,
because we've talked about
individual family limitation
issues,
trying to keep the kid alive.
If the village is resource
limited they may have mechanisms
for keeping the whole population
of the whole village down,
and so in Africa especially,
they have a thing called
terminal abstinence.
That means at a certain point
in life the culture demands that
you stop having sexual
relations.
Very often this is when your
daughter has her first child.
After that you're a
grandmother, and you're not
supposed to reproduce anymore.
It's interesting what--to
prevent--they perceive it as
preventing conflicts between
their duties as mother and their
duties as grandmother,
so a grandmother is supposed to
help raise the grandchildren.
And there's a lot of biological
theory about why do humans,
somewhat unique among animals,
why don't we just die --
females especially after their
fertile period,
there's no reason for you to
evolutionarily stay alive,
most animals they don't have a
post-menopausal period.
The theoretical reason is the
grandmother effect,
that as a grandmother you
support the children of your
child,
and that increases their
survival, and so it's
evolutionarily good.
Here in these tribes in Africa,
are basically saying the same
thing that if you're a
grandmother you're going to have
a conflict between taking care
of your own children and taking
care of your daughter's
children,
and that conflict is bad so you
have to not engage in sexuality.
Up to the middle of the 1900s
in Ireland,
rural Ireland,
people lived in households with
many members of both sexes and
several generations,
big multi-family houses.
The Irish believe that there
should be only one sexually
active procreative couple in the
household, so they also practice
grandmother abstinence.
These cultural items are--they
may seem a little outlandish to
us in our modern day but they
were effective.
They kept that society going.
Another issue is exogamy,
that just like chimpanzees,
it's again in most animals,
it's the males that disperse,
but in chimps and humans it's
the females that disperse.
The females leave the community
at birth,
to go live with the man's
family, and so she's under the
control then,
in many cultures basically a
slave to the son's family,
and the reproductive rules are
then set by the son's family and
she has no choice in this and
we'll talk about that extra--
this out marrying--remember
with chimpanzees they were
hostile to the neighbors around
us,
human societies are that same
way.
The professor in the lab next
to me is from China,
a village near Shanghai,
and he describes this to me in
China,
and he says my village,
which have all the same name as
him,
it's all a male bonded,
the males have been there
forever,
they all have the same last
name--they're hostile to all the
villages around them so they
won't marry the village around
them.
To get married they have to go
two villages away and they're
still sort of enemies.
In New Guinea where all over
the world that's the same
problem,
you're fighting with your
neighbors,
and yet you have to get wives
from somewhere,
you have to exchange genetic
material,
otherwise you get inbreeding
and so the Mae Enga they say in
New Guinea that we marry our
enemies and--
this is a great story.
Time is up;
I will continue this story next
time.